Valentine's Day right around the corner
and this is such a nice time of year
Valentine's Day yeah coming up in a few
days I'm sure a lot of you have planned
something romantic like a nice dinner
excuse me coming Conan it you know mine
I just like to say one thing this is a
really weird night
sure sir go ahead what is it I'm really
sorry to interrupt but you know how
you're just talking about Valentine's
Day and romance and stuff well I uh I
just want to come on Matt you can do
this you okay you seem you seem nervous
yes yeah this is crazy but here goes
I just want to ask you while we're here
at our favorite TV show if will you
marry me this is this is incredible this
is a live proposal I don't think we've
tried that on our show before that's
amazing
oh you know come on you want to go on
this journey together what do you say I
don't know this guy wait wait what do
you mean you know this guy is this is
this like a brand new relationship no no
I mean I've literally never met him he's
just sitting next to me at the show also
I'm here with my boyfriend
let's go on a map wait a minute don't
shake his hand miss I'm really sorry
about this this is weird
thanks Kona in it and don't feel sorry
for me I don't feel glad
why are you wait are you excuse me are
you sure you want to marry a complete
stranger I mean he did propose to me on
television and I think what's your name
again
I think Matt could really be the one mr.
O'Brien
we'd be honored if you'd perform the
ceremony right here right now
ok alright I guess we are gathered here
today to witness this beautiful union
between Matt and I'm sorry what is your
name
clothespin it's a beautiful name thank
you this beautiful union between Matt
and clothespin yeah if you don't mind
we've actually we've written our own
vows oh my god Matt from the moment we
met a minute and a half ago I knew that
we had something special you have always
been so thoughtful laughing at all of
Conan's jokes even the terrible ones and
I loved during the warmup when you sing
along to bare naked ladies and you knew
all the words in the rap section will
you suddenly sit next to me at TV show
tapings until death do us part
I will and to whom it may concern
sometimes when we touch the honesty's
too much
will you be my little chickadee China
the Chinese chicken okay by the power
vested in me I now pronounce you husband
and wife congratulations I guess
[Applause]
and that's how you get out of a cone and
take me
[Music]
[Applause]
you